and fears are growing in the ukrainian
port city of odessa that it could become
russia's next target the city has
imposed a weekend curfew after the
missile attack in kramer dramatorsk
odessa is on the black sea which is
strategically important to both sides in
this war over the last few days russia
has launched two attacks near the city
even before these latest attacks
many ukrainians mostly women and
children have been leaving odessa
and for some it's been a heartbreaking
decision
it's hard very hard
we sent my daughter in law with the kids
and we'll stay here i don't know how
it's going to be i hope we'll meet again
the city looks calm
but on friday russia launched two
attacks on the region
our enemy conducted an attack with the
shore missile complex bastion on the
village of krasnodka
unfortunately people were killed and
wounded
infrastructure was damaged
also the enemy launched another missile
attack near odessa fortunately no one
was wounded
on odessa's shoreline there are warnings
of mines but that doesn't stop people
from being outside
as much as is allowed
a curfew between 9pm and 6am is now in
place
because of fears of more attacks
for those still here life goes on
but no one knows what will become of
this city
or to those who were left behind
and for more on that uh we're now joined
by dw correspondent jan philippe schultz
who is in ukraine for us
ian faced with the images from mario
paul and the latest deadly attack on
civilians in krematorsk will odessa be
next
well uh it's definitely a possibility
and the
atmosphere in the city is very tense at
the moment a lot of people say that the
port city is probably very high on
putin's new priority list as
part of his plan to cut off ukraine from
the black sea but at the same time
people in the city are not panicking
they believe in the power of their
military the city administration
issued a new curfew for all of sunday
sunday is a very special day
for
odessa this coming sunday because it's
the day when people in the city usually
celebrate the liberation from the nazi
forces so it's a very bitter irony that
at a time where they should be
celebrating they have to
worry about a possible new occupation
how well prepared is the ukrainian
military to protect this city odessa
i think it's very well prepared
from what we hear
the
roadblocks are in place
tank barriers
are in place
air defense systems
are operational and also the city is
prepared for a possible landing attempt
from the seaside as well so
people are prepared they are willing to
defend their city and they have a very
strong belief in the power of their
military
now uh european commission president
osola fonda line has just been to keep
offering ukraine a fast track into the
european union
what does this mean for ukraine
it it means a lot
the visit was highly appreciated
especially
also the fact that she personally came
to kiev
also of course her announcement to speed
up the eu application process
was very well received by the ukrainians
even though no concrete promises were
made and of course the the main issue or
one of the main issues for the ukrainian
side
remain unsolved and this is
europe's continuous import of of oil and
gas from russia
all right jan philippe shorts they're
reporting for us from ukraine thank you
so much
thank you
dw's rebecca haritas is in a nipro in a
central eastern ukraine which is being
used as a hub for refugees fleeing their
homes in the south and the east of the
country uh rebecca tell us what's the
situation where you are
i'm here at nepal station and as you
said it's a hub for people leaving
unfortunately people can't stay in nepal
the mayor's actually advise women and
children and anyone who can to get out
of this area uh in as soon as possible
while they still can basically but as
we've been here today we've seen
hundreds of people arriving at the
station behind me
trying to get on either evacuation
trains or simply buy a ticket
on in any empty seat to get further east
to safety these people have been coming
from
the largely eastern parts of the country
and south
east but of course tensions are very
high here as you have been reporting
this morning about that uh attack on the
kramatorsk train station that's about
200 kilometers east from where i'm
standing and obviously that has
heightened tension everyone here is
worried that that's going to happen in
fact we've been able to film inside the
station on the platform or anyone
getting onto any trains because
authorities are really worried that
something like that could happen here
i mean how are these people who arrive
there i mean surely they must be
traumatized very weary certainly how are
they being looked after before they move
on
well there's a shelter that's been set
up here it's being supported by the red
cross largely run by local authorities
excuse me there's just a tram going
behind me so i hope you can hear me
so that shelter is there for people who
are arriving here they can stay a couple
of nights or a night uh have you know
some refreshments have a hot meal get
some clothes and then sort of move and
then move on that's why the the trains
that leave in the afternoon the
station's starting to fill up because
the people come out of those shelters
and try and get onto those trains i
actually spoke to somebody who's been
volunteering at that stage at that
shelter since the beginning uh since
it's been open from early march and i
asked her how she felt working in the
aftermath of the kramer taurts attack
and whether or not they're worried about
something happening here this is what
she had to say
it was not there
you know if i imagine that situation
happening here
i wouldn't be able to work here
and create the calm space and support
these people need
a place where they can sleep without the
sound of explosions
no
rebecca because you're there and you one
can tell heightened alert and people uh
are still holding their grounds trying
to help those that need help
um
will you stay put
um well where and where not where
actually we'll be leaving a lot of
people here though have said that they
are going to stay like like um
like the woman i spoke to it from the
shelter
these people don't necessarily want to
leave their homes unless they feel it's
absolutely necessary lots of people here
in nepal say they're going to stay here
stay around they don't feel that it's
too dangerous yet but as we've seen in
other cities too too too late it can be
really dangerous as well so definitely
uh people the the refugees that have
been arriving here will be moving on but
a lot of people still sticking around
here in nepro all right uh rebecca thank
you so much for your reporting and to
stay safe
you